der machtbesessene diktator vladimir
putin fällt am 24
februar in die ukraine ein seine vision
ist dass die gesamte ukraine zu
übernehmen es ist ein teil seines
traumes das sowjetische reich wieder
auferstehen zu lassen die ukraine wäre
damit nur der erste schritt sollte die
ukraine eingenommen werden würde nach
bild -informationen eine
marionettenregierung installiert werden
an der spitze dieser regierung würde
wohl der ehemalige und vertriebene
präsident der ukraine wiktor
janukowytsch stehen dieser ist wohl
schon in linz gelandet um sich
vorzubereiten
weiter gehen experten davon aus dass
putin ein brutalo regime aufbauen wird
unter anderem mit konzentrationslagern
für seine gegner die sanktionen des
westens würden bleiben das heißt dieser
neue terrorstaat müsste autos
lebensmittel und so weiter selbst
herstellen das führt zu konflikten
außerdem wäre ein solches sowjetreich
auch für den westen sehr gefährlich ein
angriff auf die nato ist damit
vorprogrammiert
wahrscheinlich ist dieses szenario
darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit dem
historiker michael wolffsohn jetzt bei
uns ja wie wahrscheinlich halten sie
dieses szenario putin gewinnt
also dieses szenario ist viel zu
schwarz-weiß die wirklichkeit ist
vielschichtiger es scheint
bedauerlicherweise
dass der konventionelle militärische
sieg der russischen armee waren auch
immer stattfinden wird das phase 1 waren
die zu ende geht kann niemand wirklich
vorhersagen es kann zu einer blockade
der großen städte kommen allen voran
kiew das wäre sozusagen eine kopie der
wehrmacht blockade gegen die heimatstadt
putins damals jene grad heute sankt
petersburg das ist ein klassisches
mittel der militärischen kriegsführung
aber dann beginnt phase 2
viel länger dauern als in diesem
szenarium dass sie hier vorgestellt
haben und wo sie einfach das
übergangen haben es ist ja nicht so dass
mit diesem dann zu erwarten der
militärischen sieg der russischen armee
der krieg der ukraine aufhören würden im
gegenteil der beginnt dann erst das
heißt nicht nur häuserkampf sondern dass
wenn dieses marionettenregime
installiert wäre oder wer auch immer
dann die ukraine unterdrückt es zu einem
langen und sehr heftigen geringer kam
war zugegen das russische militär kommen
wird teilweise natürlich auch gegen das
russische zivil an die ukraine verwaltet
und darüber hinaus auch gewaltaktionen
von der ukraine und ihren sympathisanten
auf russischen kerngebiet also sie
müssen hier diese örtlichkeiten in den
größeren zusammenhang stellen außerdem
hat ja russland vorposten sozusagen
inzwischen weise die gruppe wagner
genannt haben in mali in zentralafrika
wird da kann man ja auch gegenmaßnahmen
einsetzen also sie müssen sehr viel mehr
faktoren hier berücksichtigen aber der
entscheidende punkt ist phase eins in
der suppe finden wir uns jetzt
klassische konventioneller krieg phase 2
wird lange dauern rea die wir kennen das
aus vietnam kennen das aus afghanistan
und wir wissen dass da der david in der
regel gewinnt
in diesen szenarien die sich jetzt
gerade schildern herr professor wolf
sondern wie ist eigentlich unsere rolle
also wir haben jetzt sanktionen
beschlossen die auch natürlich erheblich
sind die auch die erste wirkung offenbar
in teilen russlands zumindest zeigen
aber ansonsten schauen wir jetzt
ja das ist die tragische situation die
fehler die gemacht worden sind in der
vergangenheit können nicht per
knopfdruck korrigiert werden die
bundesregierung der westen insgesamt
führt jetzt eine durchaus überzeugende
politik gut ab sowohl inhaltlich als
auch
rhetorisch
ausgesprochen gut ohne krieg systeme
sondern sachlich und versucht der
ukraine mit defensivwaffen zu helfen
aber nein wir können nichts tun das ist
das schreckliche wir können
demonstrieren wir können am sanktionen
verhängen aber auch sanktionen sind eine
zweischneidige geschichte oder eine
zweigleisige geschichte es ist ja nicht
nur so dass russland davon getroffen
werde sondern auch wir sind sicher
innere an die dramatisch steigende
inflation das bedeutet dass jeder von
uns für alles mehr bezahlen muss und ich
weiß nicht ob die durchhaltefähigkeit
unserer deutschen und westlichen
wohlstandsgesellschaft in der lage ist
für die überzeugung dann auch diese
opfer zu bringen und das heißt dass wir
im wahrsten sinne des wortes mehr
bezahlen müssen aber viel machen können
wir nicht es sei denn wir wollen eine
erweiterung des krieges und das wollen
wir nicht es ist eine tragische
situation und was wir daraus lernen ist
dass jede nation die gefährdet ist und
es sind sehr viele vorzeitig dafür
sorgen muss sich selbst verteidigen zu
können und da hätten wir vorher helfen
können und müssen und das ist in der ära
trotz der großspurigkeit von trump auch
von der obama bescheidenheit und
auch merkel und kohl nicht geschehen das
ist unsere versäumnisse
sie zeigen daten noch einmal ganz
deutlich die versäumnisse auf und wir
schauen auch währenddessen in die
ukraine und beobachten wie sehr die
menschen sich wehren wie sehr der
widerstand groß ist und es scheint fast
so dass putin damit gar nicht so genau
gerechnet hätte und da kommt natürlich
kam der gedanke auf dass
vielleicht ein wunder passieren könnte
das alles noch mal eine ganz andere
wendung nehmen könnte eine ganz
realistisch fundierte einschätzung von
ihnen ist dieses dieser hoffnung auf
dieses wunder in irgendeiner form
realistisch völlig unrealistisches kann
kein wunder geben es kann nur das
passieren wofür die grundlagen gegeben
sind und
wunder passieren in der religion das ist
eine metaphysische angelegenheit eine
außerirdische angelegenheit woher soll
denn jetzt der widerstand kommen er
kommt aus der geringe bewegung juri
gagarin heißt dass aus dem konkret
gesagt ukrainischen zivil fällig und
berechenbar für das russische militär
und zivil angriffe und werden das ist
kein großangriff das sind viele viele
angriffe die in ihrer summe dann den
angreifer also russland kaputt machen
werden nicht nur einen hohen preis an
menschen und material sondern eben auch
politisch und das dauert aber lange
denken sie doch da man wie lange die
taliban gegen die internationale allianz
gekämpft haben von 2001 bis zum sommer
20 21 20 jahre denken sie daran wie
lange der vietnamkrieg gedauert hat herr
professor wolf so in vielen dank an den
historiker für diese einordnung